well i'll let's talk about hope i have
something that i think could very easily
explain some optimism for everybody you
used to be a woke journalist
and you're no longer
you wrote a book against it yeah so tell
me like how do you how do you find
yourself like how do you end up as a
woke reporter and then one day have an
unwokening and become
anti-woke
yeah my deprogramming
it was like a bunch of things you know
like very slow and then all at once but
i definitely had the trump derangement
syndrome it was like in the beginning it
was very hard for me to talk to
to i took it very personally that he won
in that super lame liberal way and um it
you know it took me a while to be able
to admit like oh that's a really good
thing he did and that's a really good
thing he did but um my deprogrammings i
think it started with hearing learning
about the deaths of despair and and
every night i would turn on cnn and see
the very people
who we had abandoned who were literally
killing themselves because they didn't
see a future for themselves in this
country
you know killing themselves being mocked
on cnn being called racist in the new
york times like and i could that sort of
started to really like it was jarring to
me like why are we why do we not have
compassion for them
and then the second thing i would say
was um i read this yale study from 2018
do you guys know about this study no
you're really there's a lot of studies
from here you're really gonna love this
one though you do right yeah maybe um so
and yale did a study in 2018 what they
found was there's a difference between
how white liberals and white
conservatives talk to black people i
remember this study great study oh yeah
top tier and um it found that white
liberals dumb down their vocabulary when
they're talking to blacks and latinos
and white conservatives do not and i
remember reading that in 2018 and
thinking to myself this implicates my
entire worldview and i was not ready to
deal with it and i put it aside but i
had this moment where i was like this is
disgusting and everything i think is
caught up in that thing that makes you
dumb down your language you assume a
person of color is less educated than
you is poorer than you and needs your
help and needs your generosity and your
beneficence right that move of like i
instantly recoiled because i i
recognized it and then the third thing
that really i think was like the death
of my trump arrangement syndrome was my
rabbi is
just the best person that i know he he's
the kind of person who like in the
winter he walks down the stream he sees
a homeless person he starts taking his
clothes off and giving them his coat and
his scarf and everything he's just the
most humble generous person i know and
we were you know having a shabbat meal
once and you know trump came up and he
was like oh i love trump and i was like
excuse me and he was like yeah i love
the guy and i was like you mean you
voted for him you know holding your nose
and he was like no i love him and it was
like that and that's what i tell people
people often ask me like how can i
convince people to not be woke anymore
and what i say is like you can't really
change someone's mind with information
our brains aren't wired that way
what you can do is you can be a person
who is so humble and virtuous or strives
to be virtuous so clearly trying to be a
good person that a person who disagrees
with you can no longer say about
everyone who holds your opinion
you're they're racist they're evil but i
think that's uh uh for liberals it's a
liberal perspective i think
conservatives have a tendency to be
swayed by facts and information
not all of them obviously obviously
there's very emotional people and i
think the left has a tendency a tendency
to be swayed by feelings it's why ben
shapiro tweets interesting facts don't
care about your feelings and gets 50 000
retweets and a million followers and
everyone's cheering for them on the
right and on the left
they're very much driven by you know
care and fairness to sites specifically
jonathan heights researchers yes of
course conservatives have all six moral
foundations the liberals have two but
when ben shapiro says facts don't care
about your feelings he's kind of making
an emotional statement
you know
but but it's the stands
and the inverse is true for the left
feelings don't care about your facts but
uh jonathan heights research found that
uh conservatives when they take a moral
foundations test they have a balance of
all these different moral foundations
which is it's what care fairness purity
authority um freedom yeah and there's
one more
uh but you're super anti-authoritarian
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah i mean i think i
think
i i think the divide the political
divide is it's obviously not left or
right yeah it's authoritarian versus
anti-authoritarian
so if you're someone who uh i think
liberals have a tendency towards
authoritarianism i hate using the word
liberal because it doesn't mean that
yeah but whatever modern american
leftism is
because they're collectivist
and collectivism is inherently
authoritarian because if the collective
which is the authority decrees you
either follow suit or you're ostracized
so if you're someone who is driven by
care and fairness and that's it you
don't care about loyalty purity
authority or anything like that or
freedom liberty is a is a moral
foundation and if you don't have that
well then you don't care if they're
doing vaccine mandates let me tell you
something i think people really need to
understand the left and the right don't
speak the same language
they come out right now in new york city
and they say vaccine mandates work let
me just ask you a very simple question
do you think vaccine mandates work no
why not
well i think they're unconstitutional
well that's not a question of what you
mean do they work at preventing this i
didn't say that i said do they work do
they work and you with no qualifications
no qualifications do you think they work
do i think they work i don't think they
work and why is that well because of
omicron
so this is really interesting because
people left know this they know new york
is experiencing a massive surge in cases
but when they say vaccine mandates work
they're not talking about preventing
covid they're talking about forcing
people to adhere to the collective which
is you must get the vaccine regardless
of the outcome
on the right they say vaccine mandates
don't work
because covet is still spreading like
crazy
so that's a really interesting
distinction between the two cultural
definitions of the word work
right yeah um um the the left today is
also deeply meritocratic not not in the
sense of a real meritocracy but in the
sense of their deeply careerist and
deeply obsessed with credentials and
that's not meritocracy it's it's it's
okay okay so agree we disagree about
well it's authoritarianism it's uh look
getting getting getting a college degree
doesn't prove you're a journalist
but it's very individual it's like the
desire to rise above the pack and tell
everybody else what to do and become
famous and be like that to me seems
really individualist like no no no i
mean uh in north korea you want to be a
party member in china you want to be a
party member you want to be a part of
the collective at the highest ranks to
prove your value to the authority
whereas uh on the right you have
tendency towards libertarianism which is
get off my property and leave me alone
right when when someone says go to
college and get a degree they're not
saying get an education they're saying
adhere to the cult adhere to the
authority
you get it's remarkable to me i meet so
many people who are you know i'm going
to go to college and get a degree and
then get a job i'm like what is that
degree going to do for your job or what
you want to do nothing
they admit this they say it's a piece of
paper that proves you've done something
millennials my entire life have said
this when i'm like what's the point of
getting a college degree it just proves
you did it that's authoritarianism the
adherence to the authority me i've
always been libertarian i dropped out of
high school i said screw college i'm
going to make my own way and decide for
myself and i don't care what you think
and you can't tell me what to do
conversely or subsequently i don't want
to tell you what to do either just leave
me alone those are the those are the big
differences but isn't populism and
libertarianism in tension with each
other
um not necessarily why why do you think
that because libertarianism to me
signifies like
free trade and well that's big l liberty
you're like a civil libertarian civil
libertarian yeah yeah it's just uh do
you have a tendency towards live and let
live or do you have a tendency towards
do as you're told right what we should
call liberalism except liberals exactly
don't believe in that new york city now
st paul uh minneapolis they're now
enforcing a vaccine mandate cook county
the second biggest county in the country
vaccine mandate and we're watching
record covid cases
so what is the point of the vaccine
mandate
they repeatedly say it works that on tv
they say it works in new york they say
it works well it's not stopping kovid
oh but the vaccine minutes are
getting people to drop down bend the
knee and give in to your authority in
that in that sense it is working and
that's exactly what they mean when they
say it works
yeah and they're finding people and then
i look at luke
i'm already i already have something
lined up i'm sure you're talking about
what was happening in quebec with of
course the premier there setting up a
tax on the unvaccinated he's calling it
a health contribution but in reality
it's just theft uh the prime minister of
canada justin trudeau also says that he
supports this strong measure and most
likely will be implementing uh this kind
of exploitative measure on the canadian
public as a collective you better be a
part of our gang or we're going to steal
your money that's essentially what's
happening right now in quebec and what's
going to happen nationally throughout
canada in a few days look at this
article from the la times mocking
anti-vaxxer's deaths is ghoulish yes but
necessary it is yes no no it isn't it
convinces no one of anything
what is the purpose of mocking an
anti-vaxxer's death
seriously it's to gloat so that people
on your side can laugh and feel like
they're part of the the group i call it
a cult because the way cults work is
convincing a person that everyone loves
you you're right you're on the right
side and they're the crazy people don't
listen to them don't talk to them is
that a photo of the author no that's a
photo of women who died
due to covet who opposed mandates okay
because i was going to say that that's
like of that publication to use the
photo of the author would have been like
clearly signaling what had happened here
which was like
they knew that this piece was going to
go viral for hate and they were putting
a target on the back of the author and
they like this is something no edit i'm
saying this is an opinion editor this
piece got a ton of track the kind of
traffic like you dream of as an editor i
would never have let somebody write that
because you just know that it's it's so
ghoulish and it's just going it's only
going to get hate shares and essentially
it's like
this this editor just did not have the
back of that writer it's not just one
editor i mean how many people are
probably involved in the process of this
getting approved
so if our goal is to make a better
country and to help people
do you think it makes sense to go to
someone whose wife just died of covet
and laugh and mock them and say your
wife's up an effing [ __ ] what a dumb
piece of garbage haha and then high five
your friend is that going to convince
them to to join you is it going to
convince them to get vaccinated
no so actually interestingly people
don't know this but um
walmart has had a campaign to help
vaccinate people and it has been
incredibly successful in the two most
vaccine hesitant populations african
americans and trump voters as well as
evangelicals big overlap there and when
they asked them like why are you
succeeding with these populations that
nobody else can get vaccinated their
answer was we're meeting people where
they're at and they had they they they
partnered with low local leaders who had
a lot of trust in the community sports
teams or pastors or there was one
community of latinos who were very
vaccine hesitant and they found a local
publication in spanish and they had a
press conference in spanish
and then partnered with an immigration
center and so you know i i i know you
guys are probably ambivalent about this
but basically what they found was that
meeting people where they were at was
the vaccine like that was how you but it
was the opposite of a mandate opposite
of shaming um yeah respect respecting
people's distrust because you earned
their distrust by being you know you
know untrustworthy yeah do you do you uh
is there is there is zero improvement in
this country by mocking people you you
uh you know who have opposed mandates
if someone's wife dies of covid and you
show up you're wearing a suit at the
funeral and you walk over and you pat
him on the shoulder and shake his hand
and say i'm sorry for your loss i'm here
if you need anything here's my number
seriously give me a call we'll grab a
drink at any time and then you can have
those conversations and then you can say
well you know look man i mean you look
at these numbers and people who are
vaccinated are less likely to be
hospitalized you have a real
conversation and the person might still
disagree but you're having a real
conversation are you familiar with daryl
davis yes
perfect example oh god he's amazing he's
the black jazz musician who said um i
just want to meet these these racists
who hate me who never met me that was it
he didn't have a plan to de-radicalize
klansmen he just said i'm gonna go talk
to him he drove the children of a
klansmen to see their father in jail
every week for years
and they were still racist i mean it
took years for them to stop he's amazing
yeah he just he was like well you know
how they gonna know if they don't know
and you got to talk to them and that's
and that's exactly exactly it so it is
tough though because we we have we have
the data and we discuss it quite a bit
people on the left
traditionally do not follow people on
the right and don't seek to engage with
them people on the right are the inverse
they constantly seek to engage people on
the left and they consume news from
all you know different political
spectrum political outlets
in 2016 this is what jack dorsey said
left journalists liberal journalists did
not follow right-wing journalists but
right-wing journalists follow both right
and left-wing journalists so this is why
a lot of people on the right weren't
surprised that trump won we had um i
think it was max kaiser who's not a
right-wing journalist or anything he's a
financial guy
he said uh it was him and stacy they're
you know very they have the orange pill
podcast you guys check it out if you're
interested in crypto they were in europe
i could be getting the story wrong but
the general i uh i remember uh as they
were in europe and they were hearing all
across the media that trump could never
win that everyone hated him and it was
it was a slam dunk for hillary and they
flew back to the u.s and landed in north
carolina and saw nothing but support for
trump signs everywhere and they
immediately said trump's going to win
but why was the media so disconnected
because they don't follow anyone but
themselves
so we see that still today
we actually pulled up there's a website
called ground.news
and you can put in someone's twitter
handle and see
um the the political bias of the outlets
they interact with when we pulled up
left-wing personalities it was like 80
to 100 left-wing
when you pull up moderate personalities
it's mixed when you pull up
conservatives
it leans conservative with a little bit
of left in there
but many uh conservative personalities
follow left-wing publications
people on the left don't do the same
thing but again i i just want to make
the point that like
that sounds like a story about politics
but it is also very much a story about
class you know if if these journalists
lived in working-class neighborhoods or
knew any working-class people they would
not have been so shocked by trump's
victory but they don't they live in
these extremely affluent wealthy you
know hillary clinton plus 20 districts
and this is data has showed this a a
political survey found that you know
journalists 75 of journalists live not
just in blue districts but in the most
blue districts looks like a story about
about politics but is actually a story
about class about how you know the
republican party became the party of the
working class and the democrats became
the party of you know big tech wall
street which gave more money to biden
than to trump and then highly educated
liberal elites did you see this story in
2016 from vox
june 3rd 2016
leftwingpublicationvox.com democrats are
replacing republicans as the preferred
party of the very wealthy and that is
true today and the neocon establishment
conservatives like the lincoln project
fled to support democrats and even after
2020 the lincoln project said now we're
going to go after republicans in the
senate and conservatives were like why
we thought you were the party of lincoln
you just opposed trump no
they're establishment politicians my
favorite story maybe you saw it
was during the george floyd riots there
was a guy in la
who was cheering on the riding saying
yeah yeah get it go go until the rider
started coming to beverly hills and then
he tweets something like no don't come
to my neighborhood why are you coming
here go downtown
it was amazing to see the contempt and
disdain for regular people as the riders
were destroying the neighborhoods of the
poor and he cheered them on and then
panicked we got to be careful that we
don't get too excited about the the
vindication as the the wealthy start to
suffer as their dollar gets closer and
closer to the value of zero because the
french revolution you just look at past
revolutions where people rise up against
the elite it can go really bad really
fast and you don't know who's going to
try and take power if something like
that were to happen
oh yeah rather than revel in and seeing
them fall maybe we can help them and
help them change
their behavior it's not about the
wealthy
it's about the um
who are the you know these these the the
nobles that would enter that would
inbreed and then you know
nobles was it
yeah there was one famous family where
like the guy was like oh yeah it's like
his jaw was all messed up i'm like
that's how i view most of these people
they they they are the product of this
um insular culture they've developed
where they isolate themselves from
regular people they come from old money
they're extremely arrogant and
disdainful and they think they're better
than you
and and and i know again uh i know
people i've met people throughout my
life who came from wealthy families who
became yes
became very humble
and they were like i'm really you know
peop i know some people who are wealthy
who are born into rich families who
would say you know i'm really careful to
um enter politics or anything like that
because i've not experienced what most
of the people have gone through and so i
don't want to assert myself over people
i'm like that's the right way to do it
man so tim was referring to a very
famous family called the hapsburgs since
like 1273 and they were notoriously in
an inbreeding family and developed this
weird lip
jaw deformity looking thing so check out
the hapsburg
most modern breeding
most monarchies are in bread yeah and
they would do that to maintain keep
wealth within the family yeah you know
you'd have to sell half your wealth to
your your son's wife if you're if his
wife is your daughter yeah yeah
or cousin gross i don't know i'm fairly
optimistic when i see when i see look
the success that we have everybody who's
a member at timcast.com everybody who
supports us in super chats we're growing
we're hiring we're expanding we're doing
more every single day so as a news
organization how do we taking don't or
like you were saying with subscription
model we have a core group of people
that like what we do and fortunately
what you do journalist wise is rip on
everybody that's messing up for the most
part so maybe
you don't have to target a type of
person
you know how like the new york times is
going out of their way to to supplant
these
well look i i just um
i'm anti-authoritarian
that's that that's about it so if a
person is a working-class person but
they use their voice to try and force
other people to bend the knee i'm going
to criticize them for the most part
though i'm more concerned with the power
structures themselves and the ideas
which is why in a lot of stories we
don't say the person's name or we'll
specifically reference a person who did
this instead of calling out someone
individually i don't care about an
individual i care about the structure
and the system and the person but there
are some people who are so high profile
we talk about them it's it's it's you
know nobody's perfect right
it's not it's not a perfect uh
yeah there's no simple way to ignore
everybody but there are a lot of people
uh especially on youtube
and in the political space who their
whole career is insulting and targeting
a single person oh it gets so old so
fast yeah yeah yeah but you know look
i'm optimistic i see i see the populist
growth the expansion success and i think
the censorship may be bad but you know
rumble's doing really well there's more
systems on the rise i don't think you
know
it's like all of these movies and
stories and hero's journeys uh all these
comic books about a villain who want to
take over the world and they always fail
you cannot as an individual no single
human is smart enough to seize control
of everything and they fail every time
they try oh yeah and if they were to
succeed they'd be offed by the number
two in command in a holy second and then
that guy would be offed by the number
three who would become the new you saw
in the roman empire that's why we don't
aim for
centralization of authority yep there
will come a a day where you know i walk
into the room and then everyone you know
takes a a rubber mallet hits me in the
back and then ian walks over and hits me
and i say i look up and i say you two
either time has come
you too ian let me get my hat
that's two thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you